let me say tiny looks uh very young i
gotta tell you
tiny's no spring chicken right tiny i
see
all you know tiny has come on here
numerous occasions and and described his
beauty regimen
i'm gonna say something skin is
beautiful you don't have a wrinkle in
that face oh
look at you what are you you're like 70
or something right tiny
i mean no offense that's uh it's amazing
you should do you tell you
do you admit your own age i'm near a 64.
64.
nero you got the skin of a 30 year old
look at you
what are you doing these days what are
you doing these days are you still using
the
lotions and creams quiver facts well
would you describe your beauty regimen
for the people at home because
it really does work yeah well while i
praise the good lord or no he shall
reach
renew thy youth like an eagles i praise
him first i picture you praying at home
like 20 times a week grateful for
estee lauder's uh contender loving care
and also
a wonderful makeup wonderful makeup from
revlon called age-defying makeup
is that right is there such a thing i
don't get nothing from these people
right now one of the things about tiny
when he endorses a product
he doesn't get anything free he just
wants to buy it we have had people call
into the show from
various companies and say hey tiny just
endorses we like to send them a free
this and that
he won't take it that's right he won't
take it because it's not fair to others
you know and and i don't want the
prophet here i'm just telling him what
what i do hey uh so tiny anyway so your
first wife miss vicki
she was all over the media uh making
reference to the marriage saying the
marriage was a farce
and you were wearing women's panties yes
right now it is true that when before
uh i read about cary grant that uh he
did wear bloomers
he wear panties like that yeah silk
panties and i wanted to find out how
silk
felt yes so i did buy these bloomers to
wear it
because uh to see how it feels you know
how did it feel the cotton
well it felt nice and soft it did you
like it yeah but
it didn't have any openings you know the
women's one didn't have any openings
and so i quickly discarded it and uh
one time i might have shown her into the
house but she made the world believe
that i wore it all the time there is no
shame in wearing a pair of panties once
right now i want nothing from these
people right and i'll
uh i will not advertise their products
it's not fair to the
people trying to make it in this
business go ahead but i've always used
the pens
i've always used the pens is that
correct for what time
what time because instead of underwear i
throw it away every day it's nice and
sanitary
i have no bladder control no it is not
you're wearing a diaper right now oh
yeah
it depends yeah no and you have no
bladder control no he does
he's saying no no no he just said he has
no bladder he's no problem he said i
have no problem
oh my god it's nice and soft tiny
believes in cleanliness are you wearing
the ones now that have the cotton i mean
or the fabric outside
yeah well i've always wanted that oh wow
only one i don't like about the pens
is they have those those the ones
without the hook you know they have
these
what you rip off yeah put together the
tape
the velcro like i know i don't like that
one yes it but i like the one with
what's in the loop where the button goes
in however i wish they would make
i wish they would make it hard to relate
on this topic a full
panty i like to do huggies for kids
right well i can get into it
uh just step in without those straps
that tear apart
wow wait a minute tiny you didn't like
the silk underwear because it had no
openings
right i i didn't like that and but the
depends has no opening oh yeah sure does
oh yes it does what do you know robin
have you worn a defense
the guy knows what he's talking about
tiny tiny this is amazing to me so in
other words because of your cleanliness
phobia in a way you have a germ phobia
right true
well i mean you wash the hands of
someone yes that's important yeah
but but so rather than wear underwear
that can get
fouled or have uh right right that's
right i
just i throw the pens right away every
day but i wish they would make one
where you can put it all the way up
without those straps would you like an
elastic around the top just like the
kitties have
i would like wow tiny this is faster all
depends
that will fit up their belly